two weeks away from ringing in the new
year and there is a cool spot in town
for you to welcome 2023 we are talking
about minus five Ice Bar this is such a
cool place we have Mark who is the
director of operations joining us along
with Haley to talk about what you guys
going on I hear so many great things
about this place and already I love this
these cups are made of ice absolutely so
you've got a lot going on with the new
year coming up we like to have fun we
enjoy a celebration
um and uh this year all three of our
locations we're going to be celebrating
New Year around the world so I mean
essentially most people get started at
what midnight for a champagne time right
we're going to start at 11 A.M start
with Australia uh yeah exactly right in
Pakistan as well and um just kind of go
throughout the day so anybody that's
inside the The Ice Bar we have three
locations the link Promenade we've got
uh one at manly Bay and also over at the
Grand Canal shops at the Venetian and um
you know why Nike started at 11 A.M and
you decking out on this and I can tell
you I am warm the studio was that ice
cold so this will keep you warm while
you're inside the icy conditions yeah
absolutely I mean we've got a number of
different Furs that you can choose from
a lot of fun jackets to wear and you
know it's a it's a comfortable
atmosphere and everybody kind of goes oh
my gosh in minus five how cold is it
it's really in the 20s minus five is a
Celsius hook we run it about 23 degrees
Fahrenheit and uh we're going to be
toasting throughout the day starting at
11 A.M uh by by nine o'clock we'll end
up in New York City hit Chicago hit
Denver and then toast Las Vegas in a big
way so much fun three locations you say
yes super super fast what do you got for
us that's on tap so we have two
different drinks that we're gonna pour
today we have lots of Specialties these
are my favorite
um we'll start with the Arctic Sunset so
we use the dragonberry Bacardi just a
light shot of it we'll do a little bit
of pineapple juice
a little
spill a little bit but it's okay some
Sprite top it off
nice to make the sunset do you want to
do it just a little bit how much just a
tiny bit yeah this little squirt okay
more okay perfect okay yeah good job
it's a beautiful sunset
okay come on do you work there so are
you cold all the time oh freezing yeah
I normally wear this yeah and it's just
cold yeah that would be nice
do people have trouble staying warm in
there you know not really we we keep
them busy we have a ton of interactive
things you can do in there eat scavenger
hunts QR codes uh sorbet guessing games
things like that shot skis
um we've got the best bar staff in Vegas
they love to have fun with you and once
you put on the gear get a couple of
shots in you so you're one I really
think it brings the kid out in you you
just want to stay for a while and enjoy
the atmosphere all right Haley you have
a second drink for us right the second
one is more of like a winter drink this
is the Winter's Harvest
um so let's do spice Bacardi this time
instead of the Dragon Berry just a shot
of it we will do some cranberry which is
so yummy
some of it there and then we'll finish
it with some ginger beer do you want to
pour it sure absolutely just a tiny bit
and say win a little bit more a little
bit more perfect all right
that's fantastic now do people need to
make reservations or can they get in any
time they certainly can make
reservations we can go online to the
website and make a reservation come on
in but at the door as well
um we're open at 11 A.M be open until
probably 2 A.M or even later on New
Year's Eve so uh either or that day
might be a good day to get reservations
yes all right Mark Haley thank you so
much for joining us I hope people check
you out absolutely and uh we'll look
forward to hearing more from you we